[Musique]
Brétigny-sur-Orge en France mais la
recherche rénovation pour euro contrôle
une organisation
intergouvernementale européenne nous
concentrons nous menons nos activités
dans le contexte de la gestion du trafic
Riom des drones du développement durable
et de l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle dans l'aviation nous sommes
également en centre de simulation de
premier plan en Europe en fait nous
réalisons des activités de simulation
pour permettre aux différents États
membres plus de 40 dans toute l'Europe
de faire des activités de réménagement
de l'espace sérion ou éventuellement
pour la validation de nouveaux concepts
nos activités sont pas européennes vu la
nature de leur contrôle et sont toujours
axés au support aux compagnies aériennes
aux fournisseurs de services
Orion aéronautique et aux aéroports
pour la résolution des programmes pour
la mise en place de notre programme
d'innovation nous opérons au travers en
contact direct qui nous permet d'avoir
accès à des problématiques de ce type de
partenaire et nous serons capables avec
ça de résoudre des problèmes dans un
terme très très court avec la
possibilité d'utiliser des méthodologies
nouvelles comme par exemple
l'intelligence artificielle
nous sommes aussi très actifs dans un
domaine tout nouveau on l'appelle new en
France en anglais c'est à dire les
drones la mobilité urbaine parce que en
gros il y a une demande très élevée et
une demande croissante de la part des
États européens ou des états quand même
qui font partie de leur contrôle de
mettre en place ce type de nouveau
service ce que dans le futur s'appellera
you space notre dernier domaine c'est
aussi les études et les modèles que nous
développons dans le contexte de
l'environnement pour avoir effectivement
une aviation soutenable dans le futur
pour cette raison là nous avons
développé des outils et des prototypes
qui permettent de considérer l'impact de
l'aviation dans l'environnement pour
améliorer ce type de impact dans le
futur comme est demandé normalement
aujourd'hui par toute l'Europe
notre collection avec Paris Saclay l'un
des pôles technologique les plus
importantes au monde et fait
effectivement pour pouvoir partager ce
type d'expérience que nous menons ici
dans le monde de l'aviation avec un
monde absolument nouveau qui est les
startups qui sont les écoles et une
technologie qui nous permet aussi
d'apprendre par rapport à ce qui est
fait dans un monde qui est complètement
différent dans le monde du transport
ayant de l'aviation
la visite du Centre d'Innovation
aujourd'hui qui fait partie de ce
parcours de visite dans le contexte de
Paris Saclay spring 2023 est une
occasion parfaite pour montrer aux gens
qui ne connaissent pas ce monde le
transport aérien la ronautique notre
monde la recherche l'innovation faite
dans ce domaine dans le même temps pour
nous donner des opportunités de
collaboration et coopération futures